niederlage bei der impfpflicht
abstimmung im bundestag heute es ist die
klatsche für kanzler scholz und
gesundheitsminister lauterbach die
einführung einer corona impfpflicht ist
gescheitert hatte keine mehrheit heute
im bundestag
was hatte er gekämpft geworben ja fast
schon gebettelt gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach und seine impfpflicht wir
haben heute die möglichkeit 90 prozent
der todesfälle die vermeidbar sind durch
an endlich zu vermeiden nutzen wir bitte
diese am donnerstag das duell im
bundestag abstimmung über eben diese
impfpflicht ab 60 jahren harter
widerstand jedoch aus dem lager der
impfpflicht gegner es ist nämlich nicht
die aufgabe des staates erwachsenen
menschen gegen ihren willen zum
selbstschutz finden hinzu kommt dass
mittlerweile sogar doppelt geimpfte in
der statistik als ungeimpft gelten wenn
ihre letzte impfung ein halbes jahr
zurückliegt wie gut die impfung gegen
künftige mutationen schützt weiß kein
mensch das ergebnis
683 abgegebene stimmen
296 dafür
378 dagegen neun enthaltungen eine
klatsche eine klatsche vor allem aber
auch für kanzler olaf scholz er war für
die impfpflicht sowie auch vizekanzler
robert habeck außenministerin annalena
baerbock
innenministerin nancy faeser und und und
und das volk bekämpft dreimal also bin
ich dafür ja ich bin über 60 und ich
will sie nicht also ich hätte hätte es
befürwortet wenn die absichten als
pflicht gegolten hätte also ich bin
wirklich gewusst hat ich habe alles aber
ich möchte eigentlich keine vierte spur
zu machen wir haben jetzt andere
probleme als eine impfpflicht momentan
lauterbach ist ja doch irgendwie hat er
in der letzten zeit im werk fertiges
bild abgegeben in meinen augen
und wer gedacht hat das letzte wort ist
gesprochen karl lauterbach hat bereits
angekündigt wir machen weiter das heißt
dann wohl auch karl lauterbach als
talkshow minister weiterhin auf allen
kanälen im kampfmodus hoffen wir dass
sich scholz und lauterbach bald von
ihren klatschen erholen
film aus unserer politik redaktion jetzt
hier bei mir guten abend julius das ist
schon eine richtige klatsche hier für
den kanzler aber vor allem auch für den
gesundheitsminister beide haben ja immer
wieder betont wie wichtig die
impfpflicht ist ja das ist eine klatsche
in serie ist der die ganze woche durch
am wochenende musste oder hat beginn der
woche musste wo der kompromissvorschlag
von dem team um karl lauterbach
bekanntgegeben impfpflicht ab 50 oder
sein die 80 wurde schon mal gestrichen
dann kam es zu keinem richtigen zu
keiner richtigen einigung hat man sich
angenähert und gesagt die pflicht ab 60
soll es aber sein haben sich zumindest
schon mal zwei gruppen zusammengetan
aber auch da war nicht klar werde es
eine mehrheit geben dann hat das laut
aber noch versucht mit einem
parlamentarischen trick er wollte die
abstimmungs reihenfolge ändern nicht mal
dafür hatte die ampel heute mittag eine
mehrheit und am ende wurde dann zuerst
über den antrag die endlich ab 60
abgestimmt und die wurde mit dem
niederschmetternden ergebnis
zurückgewiesen 296 ja stimmen waren am
ende nur über 340 die nein gestimmt
haben das ist schon sehr sehr deutlich
und jetzt sagt sie aber trotzdem wir
machen weiter man muss falls fragen juli
etwas hat man halt zu fürchten er hat
angekündigt dass er weiter dafür kämpfen
würde er als arzt müsse das tun und um
die gesundheit der menschen zu kämpfen
nur sagen viele andere mediziner moment
mal wir wissen noch gar nicht ob
überhaupt eine gefahr droht im herbst
wir haben im moment die oregon variante
wir erleben es alles gibt unfassbar hohe
fallzahl unfassbar hohe dunkelziffer und
trotzdem vergleichsweise wenig schwerer
schwer kranke oder tote menschen und
lauterbach geht davon aus dass im herbst
eine todbringende schlimmere variante
omikron kommt das ist nicht unmöglich
aber auf gar keinen fall die
wahrscheinlichste variante und darauf
werde sich vorbereiten oder viele
mediziner sagen
auch politiker sagen ich kann mich nicht
mit einer grundrechts einschreiten der
impfpflicht auch etwas vorbereiten von
dem ich noch gar nicht weiß ob es
wirklich kommen wird welche mittel hätte
er denn da überhaupt geht dann alles
noch einmal von vorne los also hier ist
der meeting wieder ab in den bundestag
wieder vorschläge die dann abgelehnt
werden also welche möglichkeiten hat er
überhaupt weil er gut ein gesetz
einzubringen einfach karriere wann genau
man kann als sich als gruppe versammelt
ein ein antrag oder einbringung
abstimmen lassen ob es dann eine bessere
variante ist ob es dann irgendwie
kniffe gibt die die union überzeugen die
andere fraktion überzeugen ist eine
andere frage und natürlich ganz
entscheidend wird eines tages wieder das
momentum auf der seite von curd aber
seien nämlich dass wir wieder probleme
bekommt dass wir beispielsweise im
herbst steigende fallzahlen haben bald
wieder die herbstsaison los geht die
menschen nach drinnen gehen und sich
gegenseitig anstecken vielleicht auch
die bewegung des impfstoffs nach und
nach nachlässt das momentum auf seiner
seite hat das wäre noch ein thema aber
letzten endes muss er wieder den weg
über das parlament gehen also eventuell
alles noch einmal von vorne wir sprechen
jetzt mit kassen erster chef dr andreas
kasten der uns zugeschaltet guten abend
die klatsche für den gesundheitsminister
haben sie sich darüber heute ein
bisschen gefreut oder fürchten sie auch
wie er den herbst und was da auf uns zu
kommen möge
das hat mit freunden gar nichts zu tun
also es ist ja völlig unstrittig dass
nach wie vor die impfung gegen korona
insbesondere für ältere und für
risikogruppen das sinnvollste ist und
das kann man aus medizinischer sicht nur
empfehlen dass das mit der impfpflicht
jetzt nicht gesetzeskraft erlangt hat
das ist die entscheidende dass durch den
bundestag vertreten souveräns durch dem
die bürger und das muss man glaube ich
mal akzeptieren das ist ein wenig
zielführend fünf minuten danach zu sagen
wir machen weiter ich glaube dass die
impfpflicht gescheitert ist ist auch ein
gutteil dadurch herrn lauterbach selbst
verursacht worden war ja das narrativ
was er über die letzten monate gepflegt
hat sich ständig gewandelt hat er bei
einem oktober an auch gegen eine
impfpflicht gut begründet ehrlich gesagt
und hat jetzt zuletzt begründung für
eine mögliche endlich angeführt die
offenkundig einfach nicht tragen so
hilft halt die impfung die wir im moment
haben nicht gegen eine infektion es gibt
also keinerlei fremdschutz sie hilft
individuell und da muss man natürlich
klar sagen junge gesunde menschen sind
natürlich in sehr geringem umfang nur
von der gefahr einer wirklich schweren
verlaufsform bedroht das ist eher was
von für anwalt von risikogruppen und
ältere menschen und da sollte man viel
besser eine eine impfkampagne fahren
damit die im herbst geschützt sind das
wäre glaube ich zielführend gewesen als
diese völlig erratischen diskussion mit
verschiedensten anträgen die alle für
sich nicht wirklich überzeugen konnten
sehen sie überhaupt noch erfolgschancen
für eine impfpflicht
das kann ich nicht beurteilen das ist
eine entscheidende der bundestag muss
ich habe nicht die phantasie warum
deutsche bundestag in vier wochen anders
entscheiden sollte also heute
entschieden hat es sei denn morgen ist
die
beschworene hocker variante am horizont
zu erkennen das ist bisher völlig unklar
und wir müssen doch erstmal ein
impfstoff haben dagegen eine solche neue
variante wird also ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass es hier jetzt das
parlament den nächsten zwei wochen
wieder fit ist auch nicht unser thema
das ist eine politische entscheidung
ende des tages ich als arzt und ich
vertrete ja nun die ärzte in und erst in
deutschland und die haben ein großes
bestreben möglichst viele menschen durch
eine impfung zu schützen dass es auch
unstrittig dazu stehen zur verfügung und
wir haben die impfung insbesondere für
kranke ältere menschen und andere
risikogruppen und ich denke das sollte
viel mehr über diesen aspekt laufen die
impfpflicht hat doch aus meiner sicht im
moment erstmal ausgedient
dr andreas gassen vielen herzlichen dank
ihnen für das gespräch und
wir sprechen weiter und ich begrüße
jetzt christian doerr
fraktionsvorsitzender der fdp
bundestagfraktion schönen guten abend
herr dr
das
kann man als klatsche für die ampel
verstehen sie das auch
ich befürchte herr dörr wir haben gerade
tonprobleme hier können sie leider nicht
hören wir arbeiten da noch einmal dran
ich sehe sie sind uns zugeschaltet aber
gerade ob wir dann noch einmal am ton
arbeiten damit wir sie auch hören können
daran arbeiten wir jetzt mein kollege
aus der politik noch weiter bei uns im
studio als haben wir es gehört die
erfolgschancen wenn nicht gerade hoch
ausgerechnet und auch von ärztlicher
seite heißt es lieber eine kampagne als
die impfpflicht man hat das gefühl
dieses thema ist irgendwie vom tisch und
gleichzeitig steigt aber die
verunsicherung auch wenn wir auf die
vergangene woche blicken denn dieses
erst die quarantäne nur noch freiwillig
das wurde dann kassiert im mitten in der
nacht das löst irgendwie glaube ich bei
der bevölkerung auf 4 verunsicherung aus
hier steht die politik da gerade da
viele kommunikativ definitiv nicht sehr
gut und man kann von einem
kommunikationsdesaster sprechen was
diese woche passiert ist minister
lauterbach wollte die quarantäne pflicht
zum ersten mal abschaffen und eine ganz
logische schritt weil bei den hohen
fallzahl moment über vier millionen
menschen die gleichzeitig krone positiv
sind kommt kein besonders amt dieser
welt hinterher das wäre also einfach nur
logisch eine einer regel die auf dem
papier existiert aber auch in realität
nicht umgesetzt wird einfach
abzuschaffen ämter weniger zu tun und
die menschen er kann sich nicht wurde
aber zurückgerufen nachdem lauterbach
viel kritik bekommen hat in der eigenen
fraktion von experten aber auch vor
allem von einem harten kern an corona
maßnahmen befürwortern die bei social
media kritisiert haben so ein hin und
her sorgt einfach nur für verwirrung und
das wichtigste für maßnahmen ist
eigentlich die akzeptanz
jetzt gerade habe ich gehört ich glaube
christian doerr klappt ich ich hab ja
noch einmal nach bei uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ist werten gerade eben
technische probleme entschuldigen sie
bitte wir wollen den
fraktionsvorsitzenden der fdp
bundestagsfraktion sprechen unter ist
auch wieder christian tue jetzt bei uns
in ich hoffe auch sehr wie können sie
hören denn uns interessiert natürlich
sehr ob sie das heutige ergebnis für als
klatsche für die ampel verstehen
ja ich kann sie wunderbar vielen dank
guten abend erstmal nein das ist
natürlich keine klatsche für irgendeine
regierungskoalition sondern es war von
anfang an eine medizin ethische debatte
das heißt es war keine frage von
politischer und parteipolitischer
farbenlehre sondern jeder abgeordnete
hat für sich entschieden insofern kann
man nicht von mehrheiten aus opposition
oder regierungen dort sprechen der
deutsche bundestag hat aus der mitte
heraus entschieden jede einzelne
abgeordnete für sich ich übrigens auch
im dezember muss ich sagen hätte ich ja
nicht mehr gestatten österreicher damals
eingeführt hat sie jetzt wieder zusetzt
aus gutem grund ich bin für diese
entscheidung ist getroffen haben und es
gibt genommen haben genau zu analysieren
ob es sinnvoll ist und der kassen hatte
das ja vorhin in ihrem gespräch sehr
deutlich gesagt wir haben zurzeit keinen
impfstoff für eine variante im herbst
das heißt es würde eine impfpflicht
jetzt insofern keinen sinn machen und zu
einer politischen entscheidung wird dazu
dass man sich die dass man sich genau
informiert und entschärften trifft und
die entscheidung war ein nein für mich
im übrigen ich habe mich auch gegen eine
impfpflicht entschieden sehen sie dann
überhaupt noch erfolgschancen für die
impfpflicht wir machen weiter sagt der
gesundheitsminister also das ganze
[Musik]
also ich es geht nicht darum das ganze
noch mal von vorne zu machen das hätte
ich auch in der sache für falsch ich
glaube es geht jetzt
tschuldigung jetzt ist es etwas lauter
im deutschen bundestag
vielen herzlichen dank herr diller da
wird nun probleme nicht nur der
bundestag der durchsagen macht sondern
auch die technik spielen hier ein
bisschen verrückt wir danken ihnen
trotzdem für dieses kurze gespräch danke
dass sie sich die zeit genommen haben
und entschuldigen sie liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer dass es
dort schon probleme gab